[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here okay so
you may have been following over the
last two weeks or so i've been doing a
giant blind smartphone camera test
so not four phones not five not ten
we've done this huge bracket style
showdown with 16 phones so starting out
the idea was originally going to be a
normal couple of phones like we've done
in the past so you get pixel 3 in there
you get iphone 10s then you kind of want
like a mate 20 pro
galaxy note 9 and then probably red
hydrogen but then you leave out lg v40
or you might want to get one plus 6t in
there and then by that time the choice
is getting kind of tough so we had an
idea so instead of just taking my
subjective top few and then leaving some
out
let's just take them all let's just take
all of them so we took 16 phones all of
which that have come out in the past
year or two all of which have cameras so
pixel 3 pixel 2
iphone 10s
iphone 10
samsung galaxy note 9 huawei p20 pro
huawei mate 20 pro
red hydrogen lg v40 oneplus 6t razer
phone 2 htc u12 plus
moto z2 force pocophone f1 blackberry
key2 and the palm phone so clearly a
healthy variety of phones a variety of
cameras and now they all have their own
sort of strengths and weaknesses they
all have different characteristics to
them and there's too many now to just
try to recognize them all so you might
say oh that one looks like the pixel so
the other one must be the iphone no
there's there's too many it's just going
to go down to instinct some of them will
get knocked out quick some of them will
make it much further so it's the
people's choice winner takes all bracket
style and lots of voting
so
bracket
and then there was seating so you just
heard the names of the phones there was
a million ways we could have done this
we basically wanted to seed them
somewhat to make it make sense but we
didn't want to have the same phones like
pixel 3 versus pixel 2 against each
other we didn't want iphone 10 versus
10s in the first round so we had to
randomize it somewhat so people don't
know what they're voting for
but once we do that then we can kind of
see it play out so we filled in the
seeds a through p assigned every phone a
letter and then went to work so we went
out and took the exact same photo with
every phone for each round we tried to
pick some scenes that had a variety of
things happening almost all of them had
skin tones of some sort because people
take pictures of people and then there
were some some colors some dynamic range
some depth of field happening blue sky
sometimes red backpack other times
pretty healthy variety but nothing too
scientific then we stitch together the
photos that would be compared to each
other for every round
and let them loose
i hosted the viewing and voting in two
places as you've probably seen by now
instagram stories
and twitter instagram makes sense that's
where a lot of people are on their
phones looking at photos anyway and
that's where people share them and take
them and then with a little help from
twitter i got to use images in polls for
the first time so we posted there too so
people could vote then we totaled the
votes for every match up every round and
that's where things got
pretty fun and interesting so altogether
there were more than 5 million votes on
instagram stories and over a million
votes in twitter polls
and you're probably wondering what
people voted for you might even be
wondering if you voted what you voted
for
so
here's how it went here is the bracket
and the starting seeds from a
all the way through p now if you didn't
get the chance to vote on social already
look at this bracket and go ahead and
pause and fill it in now how you think
it would go you have the advantage of
knowing all the phones go ahead fill it
in i'll wait trust me it'll be worth it
so round one the photo of me outside red
heather jacket with yellow divider
behind me clouds in the background skin
tones pretty much everything in round
one mate 20 pro beat the palm phone
easily razer phone 2 crushed oneplus 6t
then lg v40 beat pixel 2
blackberry key2 beat iphone 10s
huawei p20 pro beat pixel 3
hydrogen slaughtered moto z2 force
and galaxy note 9 barely beats htc u12
plus
and then pocophone beat iphone 10. okay
uh
a lot of what i would call upsets i'll
be honest if i was betting like if i had
filled this out just kind of what i
thought it would be like a march madness
style thing
bracket already busted let's be real we
probably didn't see this we probably
didn't see that coming some weird stuff
happening but it is actually already
kind of starting to make sense there's
reasons for what we're seeing here
i'll explain later
round two this was the hot sauce photo
so in my hand you got warm colors cool
background not portrait mode normal
photo pretty simple mate 20 pro beats
razer phone 2.
blackberry key2 beats lg v40
red hydrogen overcomes p20 pro and the
pocophone barely beats galaxy note 9 it
actually got less votes on twitter but
enough more votes on instagram to
overcome it and win i
think that's what i would consider an
upset again happening over there but
there's still a lot of things that make
sense some things that don't but we'll
save that to the end next round round
three this is the semifinals we have the
red backpack on the brown table blue sky
and clouds in the background plus a
little shadow happening on the right a
lot of tones here again
in this photo mate 20 pro finally beats
blackberry and the pocophone f1
dethrones the red hydrogen that is um
all right last round finals it is again
skin tones red backpack blue sky and
true depth of field happening with the
fence some contrast things etc and mate
20 pro cleans up easily beating the
pocophone
raise your hand if you had a perfect
bracket
put your hand down you're lying there
are some pretty big upsets here a lot of
strange things happening but now that we
have all the photos and we have all the
voting results we can take a look back
at what happened when and why
and then it actually starts to make some
sense so looking back now at every round
what spoke to me was apparently
the most important thing to people when
viewing these photos straight out of
camera was just exposure brightness
basically nine times out of ten the
brighter more saturated more punchy
contrasty photo won every single round
it's pretty consistent there are other
differences between the photos always
color science dynamic range sharpness
even focal length sometimes and
background compression but the brighter
photo almost always won the thing is
there's not a whole lot of you know
side-by-side photo comparisons happening
on social media like twitter and
instagram you kind of just like what you
like but as soon as you put them next to
each other then people's eyes just tend
to go to the brighter photo and then
compression of twitter and instagram
pretty much ruins any sharpness or
detail advantage that the actually great
cameras tend to lean on the differences
in dynamic range weren't really all that
dramatic in the photos that i was taking
so
it just came down to which one looked
brighter next to the other one the
brighter punchier photo the funny thing
is and we all know this already but the
brighter photo doesn't necessarily make
it the better photo often people like me
and maybe some of you are actually
looking for something a little more
natural in a photo when we're evaluating
a camera i've said before i'm a big fan
of the pixel 3's camera that is a
slightly flatter more natural neutral
photo with a lot of dynamic range and
detail that's what it's good at the more
information the better because that's
what photo i can bend and adjust to make
it look like what i want later which
might be brighter or not depends on me
but as soon as you put the flat neutral
image side by side with a bright fully
processed looking one people's eyes went
straight for the more finished looking
photo so there's a first round match up
that illustrates this
beautifully perfectly and that's iphone
10s
versus blackberry
i thought that was going to be a gimme i
put them up against each other because i
figured it like any first round bracket
play that's kind of a gimme for the
powerhouse iphone will probably win that
right well this is the iphone 10s photo
pretty damn good if you ask me
and this is the blackberry photo
similar but a very different photo the
blackberry sensor is much smaller it
biases a little warmer in color
temperature but generally it is way less
sharp and less detailed than the iphone
in fact the blackberry sensor is getting
so much less light even outdoors and the
processing is so bad that it actually
thought the heather of my sweatshirt was
noise in the photo and it tries to noise
reduce or like smooth out the noise in
my sweatshirt so there is no detail in
parts of my sweatshirt here but the
iphone kept it all sharp and detailed
from top to bottom but when you toss it
up on twitter or instagram the
compression is garbage so you can forget
about any sharpness or detail advantage
you might have and that just leaves you
with the blackberry photo being a little
bit brighter a little bit warmer and a
little bit more colorful than the more
natural neutral one from the iphone and
that was all it took because when you
put them side by side on instagram 63
000 people picked the more neutral
iphone photo
and 228 000 people
chose the blackberry to win and that
made its way as a trend throughout this
whole tournament that's how pocophone
beat iphone 10. that's how p20 pro be
pixel 3 that's how hydrogen kept winning
that's eventually how mate 20 pro made
its way through the whole thing and won
it all it's the brighter less shadowy
photo so i revealed these results to a
couple a couple youtube friends and
photographer friends ahead of time to
get their reactions see what they
thought
yo
yo what's going on man first of all have
you seen or paid attention to any of the
tests we've done this week i have i have
all of them so i've voted in every
single one but i did but i used it
through twitter not through
uh instagram yes i voted
on every single one and
what what made me feel kind of good
about it is that most of the time i
voted with the majority which i actually
like i like to see that okay we're all
kind of moving towards a consensus i
voted on twitter in fact when we were
having lunch the other day all of us at
the office we gathered around we all
like made our own picks so yeah we've
been all over it so i'm going to read
you the names of the 16 phones that we
decided to put in this
bracket tell me what you think all right
pixel 3
pixel 2
iphone 10s iphone 10 uh huawei p20 pro
huawei mate 20 pro
moto z2 force galaxy note 9
htc u12 plus
xiaomi pocophone
red hydrogen
oneplus 6t razer phone 2
lg v40
palm phone blackberry key2 and the palm
phone oh that little tiny one yeah
okay so pretty healthy variety in there
yeah that's the ultimate tournament
there i feel like
there's only i only feel like the
iphone made it pretty far
i feel like i can recognize its photos i
could be wrong i would expect
obviously the palm founder just beat it
on the bottom
um
pocophone
i would have guessed near the bottom two
probably the pixel 3 the iphone 10s max
the huawei
and
let me think oh and probably like the
note or the
the samsungs
i would assume
probably
i might say the mate 20 pro so really
depends on i want to see that i want to
see the results all right
all right i'm going to dm you right now
the full bracket how it played out okay
should i text you or twitter how should
i send you the result
you can text me okay i'll text you the
actually i got i got dave2d with the
results here okay have him show you the
bracket
what though
i i was almost gonna say that oh snap
okay
[Music]
whoa
i was way off iphone got knocked out
super fast
by blackberry at that pixel 2 iphone
wait a minute
the iphone 10 the blackberry
beats
the iphone
10s
[Music]
oh my god
how did the blackberry beat the iphone
are you kidding me that is
not what i expected
[Music]
wait a minute
[Music]
okay i really didn't be expect to be
surprised
yeah or this surprised whoa that's weird
did the mate 20 pro
nice
that's it it's
all right all right dude i totally
picked h i totally faked the blackberry
that is crazy i guess my my eyeballs are
just glued to pogo phone right now
um
okay let me see this whole
um
right okay razer
the razer 2 beating the oneplus 6t
surprises the hell out of me palm didn't
make mate 20 pro poco phone poco
pocophone
300 bucks yeah there you go wow and then
p what was
the poke
[Music]
dude it's the best one you can buy it's
three
and it's the best phone i versus j
i chose j i is pixel 3 j is p20 pro
[Music]
don't worry
i did a blind test on myself and i did
the same thing oh my god dude
i voted for the i voted for the freaking
blackberry on that one
oh my god are you kidding how is this
possible
i'm
i'm actually i'm shaking right now
especially if the pocophone made it that
far and beat the hydrogen as well
and i beat the note 9 and the iphone 10
this is wild pixel 3 wow
that didn't
make it past the first round so
everything i just said
where the phones i thought would make it
to the very end no not at all
and blackberry wow see my guess as to
why like i'm gonna pull these pictures
up real quick if i had to guess why i
feel like a lot of the iphone pictures
come out like less saturated
and like maybe that's just a perceived
poor quality image something we noticed
usually usually people don't see photos
side by side very often but
when you do put them side by side right
off the bat people were picking the
brighter photo
oh no i i noticed that too
and it was
it was the photos where you were exposed
the best
that uh and usually it's harder you know
us brothers to get exposure right uh
when getting uh when the camera takes
photos of us so anything that you look
really clear i noticed i was an instant
winner it didn't matter
the dynamic range what the background
looked like if you were exposed better i
noticed that one every single time i
have seen that happen that just like the
most contrast and brightest exposure
will win but in a few of these i felt
like people were choosing the right
example like generally as i was going
through i'm like yeah i kind of agree
with this
um
so that's why that's why i'm the most
surprised i thought i was like yeah this
isn't too this isn't too bad
and now seeing the winner i'm like
that's kind of that's very crazy again
it's that brightness i think it's
similar to like volume when you listen
to headphones that are louder even if
they're not better headphones you think
they're better because there's there's
more perceived detail and depth i guess
because you don't have to discern what's
in the shadows but
yeah that's that's really interesting i
think especially when you put them side
by side because most people don't see
like direct side by side they just see
the final image
and i got a lot of comments about like i
don't know what the actual scene looks
like
yes but that's also true about most
photos you see in real life you don't
know what the actual scene looks like so
people are just picking the one they
just like the look of
dude i can't believe paco made it to the
end man you're gonna mess with a lot of
heads here i mean so i i don't pay close
attention to what the mate 20 pro or
poco phone look like when they get
released i just
kind of hear about it and slightly
ignore it so
i just
didn't even consider that might be a
possibility i hadn't even thought about
it that's interesting yeah i mean
especially if it is next to each other
but it's so hard too because it's like
you can't actually put all of these
like next to each other at the same time
and then at that point everything just
gets jumbled so this is it's such a hard
test and i feel like a lot of this too
is a preference like maybe people prefer
this type of photo over that i mean i
feel like it's art like not everyone
likes the same art you know i think what
it comes down to again is like kind of
maybe my
thought of like we're in this like
world or time of tech when nothing
actually sucks
um
there's a lot of like
amazing things like the pocophone but
yeah i think it's just a mix of
everything
maybe what it comes down to is we all
don't know anything i wonder what would
have happened had
you used like an older samsung phone
because i think
uh samsung's color science over the last
couple years has gotten really good and
really natural but remember how like
over saturated they used to look a
couple years ago i wonder if that would
have gone all the way to the top like a
like an s6 had that been used just
because it was so much more exaggerated
i think you're right i think something
like five or six years ago when they
were like punching
the reds especially wanted that backpack
photo yeah being super bright i think
that might have actually had a better
chance this is insane you know people
are going to go nuts for the focal phone
now right
they're just
ah
people already argue so much for that
phone but wow i guess it makes sense
right i mean i feel like pretty much all
the images i take on a smartphone are
viewed on other smartphones so i mean it
makes sense
yeah is this going to make you switch to
uh pocophone oh i'm a poker phone all
day man all day i'll be honest
i don't care enough about my camera in
2018 to switch a phone for it
because i feel like so many of them are
so good
i'm just surprised
like more than anything
i'm surprised
[Music]
dude
so there you have it at the end of the
day
huawei mate 20 pro was the people's
champ side-by-side blind photo
comparison smartphone camera winner of
2018. if you're looking for some kind of
scientific conclusion on which one's the
better smartphone camera from this
you're not going to get that there is no
pixel peeping a lot of the advantages of
certain cameras were eliminated but at
the end of the day you just got to know
what you want from a camera you got to
know if you want it to look great
straight out of the camera you want it
to have an ai that does some post
processing that makes it look great for
you or if you prefer a more natural
neutral looking photo if you just want
as much information as possible as much
sharpness dynamic range etc so you can
bend it the way you want later those are
two different types of people clearly
from our voting there's a lot more of
the first type of person and that's fine
so that's been the blind smartphone
photo analysis super scientific test of
2018. i hope you learned a little bit
just like i did thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace